okay let's get into this this story
really does it for me this was in black
enterprise magazine so this woman was
watching a fishing competition with her
husband
and she was looking and she realized
there was no women of color at
all so she rounded up a group of her
friends who are all mothers and
entrepreneurs
forming the ebony anglers that's right
she did something about it and now
they're
champions yeah
that's how you get it done please
welcome captain gia
babiette glenda tiana and leslie hi
[Applause]
hey
captain gia why was this important for
you to do
well it's like you said drew i was out
there with my husband
and first of all i had to get wrap my
head around the fact that yes we can
do this and so once i got my head around
that i said let me get a group of my
girlfriends together
we need to be represented as black women
we've been fishing forever
and we need to be seen fishing and it
was just one of those things let's dive
in and do it
so here we go
[Applause]
tell us about your big win well drew
our big win came as a huge surprise to
us
we did not know that at the time
we would be capturing a 48 pound king
mackerel talking about really
from that yeah you are reeling glenda
were you surprised that you did this
oh we were so surprised as we were
reeling it in
we didn't really know exactly what we
had caught we knew it was something big
but at the moment that they gassed the
fish and brought her on the boat
our 80-plus year old seasoned fisherman
captain started screaming
leslie you've started some initiatives
and you've launched them tell us about
it
well first and foremost we're mothers
and aunties so it was important for us
to pour into our children and to the
children of our community
the importance of angling and the
lessons that come with it
um they learn lessons and leadership and
fortitude and survival
and especially right now that's
something that we really want to build
with them
so we're going to use our winnings and
we're going to start fundraising and
we're going to pour back into our
programs and mentor these kids
well i really loved
talking with you in fact i am
hooked was there one lady i didn't speak
to wait did i miss anyone
see i knew it glenda how are you feeling
about this
i'm feeling great about it um i knew we
could win
um it's a great idea
will you take me fishing with you guys
sometimes i want to be
like a mascot of the ebony anglers
yes thank you for coming on the news
and sharing this story thank you ladies